I think he'll ever get out of here yeah
one day when I got a long white beard
and two or three marbles rolling around
upstairs let me tell you where I go so
hot a nail so what you are too new to
Mexico
damn Daniel back at it again with the
work today was actually kind of strange
to start with because I just came in to
perform to get something to eat first
thing and then it's about bucketing down
with rain when I was inside and I was
like well I've got my laptop I've got
everything I need with me I was gonna do
some work here so I set up for like I
don't know it's been about half an hour
just doing like I used to do issed to
keep track of all the things I need to
do and there's a lot of them I just
worked out my schedule from there for
the days and we as a as a four that's a
big and so back to the office again time
to rewrite another chapter
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Batcave I
presume this was just preceded by a
bunch of time lapses because apparently
that's all my videos are anymore see
I've been working all day and to be
honest I don't really have the mental
RAM to deal with filming anything
complicated so sorry sorry these videos
are gonna be a little bit boring but my
life is boring and these videos are
about my life so you signed up to this
today has been really productive
certainly the second half for today I've
noticed this right I seem to have a
Solero bump like every time I have gone
to the marketplace at like 4 or 5 and
I've wanted to get something as a snack
a couple of times I've had a Solero and
like today was one of those times every
time including today that I've done that
I've had a massive productivity boost
until late in evening I selling in them
I've been running stuff on both machines
I've been doing a new technique which
I've never actually done myself before
called multiple linear regressions which
is basically where you estimate what a
variable is going to be in the future
based on how it's varied with other
variables in the past that's a very bad
explanation but it's magic basically
what I'm saying is it's magic and I've
been doing that to simulate a process
which given other assumptions I'm making
about my theory if I can't work out
directly so that's been really cool
actually learning how to do that in
Python I've also been rewriting the
theory chapter I actually picked up a
mistake in one of the derivations
there's a geometric factor that was
missing so you know it's been good I've
rewritten it anyway although to be
honest I feel like maybe my supervisor
should have picked up on that mark and
now I'm rerunning a bunch of code to do
a full version of the multiple linear
regression because I only had about two
years worth of data and there's 35 years
to go through so that's running
overnight on the laptop and then I am
just finishing off to rewrite to chapter
3 on the main computer I'll be honest
with you half a day off isn't much
already feeling very tired there's just
a lot to do I've just got to keep
motivated keep my levels up and just
keep working so if you wait about at
this point if I want something to have
gotta learn it it's gone half a I am too
tired to carry on I'm gonna have to come
back tomorrow and just hit it hard
trying get hit before 9:00 Hey so it's
bit later it's now like getting on for
10 I just had to do some chores and you
know eat a bit annoying and now I'm
editing the podcast this has gotta be
ready for Saturday morning
so it's either gonna be tonight or
tomorrow night and kind of an in editing
mood I've been looking forward to
editing all day that really says
something doesn't it
I've been looking for is doing something
that other people do for a job here we
go yeah here we go
I don't think I'll be doing this to
yourself Annie it's just shitty pipe
dreams
I mean Mexico is way to hell down there
and you're in here and that's the way it
is
yeah right so it is it's down there and
I'm in here
I guess it comes down to a simple choice
really get busy living or get busy dying
so today I actually feel pretty more
chill than I have any right to be for
some reason this morning and if it's
because it was like the music I was
listening to when I came in but I just
feel really kind of chill about
everything I had a good morning
basically finishing off the multiple
linear regression stuff from yesterday
working out given a model how you save
its file and then apply it to new data
so that's a big win like momentum for in
momentum I also bought a whole bunch of
new books today which I really didn't
need to do because I've got plenty of
home I still haven't read but I can't
help it alright I have got to stop
buying new books I'm also quite possibly
a good me because I just discovered that
Pizza Belle is gonna come visit me this
weekend which wasn't planned
because basically she's gotta go off to
Cambridge to do her PGCE and yeah we
weren't expecting to get visiting so I'm
really quite happy about that well so
you might have noticed I had to trim my
beard basically through just getting
stuck in it I'm not used to having a
beard now the rule is I'm not allowed to
shave until I hand in my thesis but um I
basically trimmed it a little bit feels
weird it's it's literally growing on me
gotta say nowadays give me another late
finish something's going great so here
late and doing a bunch of rewrites
because car this morning was coding this
afternoon and evening are going to be
rewrites based on other people's
feedback and then maybe even doing the
big scary run to see if the hypothesis
is right after all
[Music]
uh-huh uh-huh Chia see yeah sorry about
that
I am not released to carrying the charge
around with me so it's currently called
at 10:00 I got back home at like I don't
know quarter past nine or something um
really long day but a lot of stuff done
I've added a whole new section to my
theory chapter and I've been populating
that with results like it's it's only
becomes clear how much work you've done
after you've finished the chapter I'm in
the middle of it at the moment and I
think like it's difficult to see the
wood for the trees almost with a number
of things I'm trying to do it's like
I've got like four different sections
kind of on the go at once and the kind
of all depend on each other and I think
yeah once tomorrow hopefully I'll be
able to finish this all off and it'll
become nice and clear and hopefully be
much much better than it was before
because looking back on as I did with
chats to looking back on what I thought
was you know thesis standards definitely
wasn't and it's like now I read it it's
like yeah this is I'm sure we see four
guys my supervisors I'll disagree but I
think this is solid as a rock
now today is still not done though
because I still need to finish off the
wiki cast also because everything just
keeps breaking at the moment like mine
was a bit of a tip I think I just
cleaned some stuff up but oh right I'm
gonna crack on with editing so I'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
today I've been working on Chapter three
continuing to edit it and we've gone
beyond the point of just ripping out
whole sections and putting new ones in
we're now at the point where it's like
you know this figure that I did I'm not
happy with I want to trim data at
beginning at the end I want to make this
line thicker gained through all coding
regenerating plots there is still some
new plots that needs to be done which
means like new analysis or rather
there's analysis but I've done but it
doesn't look good
like for some reason it just it works
but it isn't showing what it should
gonna see something crazy this is the
view from the level 8 balcony which
means this bit you can sit on the view
if you go over the edge does that fall
off there it's definitely been slower
going today than I would have liked I
don't know what it is maybe I'm just
getting tired but yeah I'm just I'm
slower than I than I need to be I'm
getting stuff done but I've been here
since admittedly I did get here quite
late I was here like 10:00 10:30 and
it's currently 5:00 so it's still
basically a full workday and what I've
done is I've summarized really really
crucial paper put it in like I say
redone a bunch of plots gone to the
whole thesis as I the whole chapter and
basically shored up a lot of mass
changing a lot of the spacing of
equations but I wanted to have done more
by now I have also been coming out here
and doing some time lapses because it's
a really nice day it's also quite
distracting having this amazing view who
spends all his time working on his own
címon arc space
[Music]
by desk so force myself to walk away at
seven o'clock because as I mentioned
earlier I'm very dark now as I mentioned
earlier live is coming down to visit so
I'm actually taking tomorrow off
yeah get busy living or get busy dyin
that's goddamn right
you